We have evolved specialized defenses to particular environmental insults
including starvation,
dehydration,
cold and heat hypoxia,
fight or flight pain and tissue repair and blood clotting.
A few general comments about these,
the hostile environmental factors frequently encountered elicit the evolution of
defense mechanisms that protecting in specific adverse effects.
Yeah.
The common defense mechanisms are actually modified extensions of homeostatic
systems that are always operating even when the environmental challenges
absence.
Okay.
This is particularly clear with defenses against starvation,
dehydration,
and extreme temperature.
Okay.
Many defenses also have specialized characteristics that are only expressed
under conditions of environmental stress.
First,
starvation,
our metabolism undergo undergoes quite normal homeostatic changes between meals,
glycogen and lipid synthesis,
right after a meal or followed by Glucose neogenesis a few hours later before
the next meal.
Yeah.
During prolonged fasting,
glycogen stores are depleted and life policies and live at oxidation or
activated to provide fuel glucose allocation shifts to the brain.
When starvation begins,
the liver start synthesizing ketone bodies that become the main fuel for most
tissues,
including the brain.
Yeah.
And when starvation is extreme,
the breakdown of protein and skeletal muscles starts to provide amino acids as
fuel sources.
Okay.
That means that metabolic defenses against extreme food deprivation are the
extensions of the fastening response that occurs normally between meals.
Okay.
What about dehydration and volume depletion
are cardiovascular and our renal systems are normally operating homeostatically
to maintain blood volume and vascular blood pressure.
Okay.
Angiotensin aldosterone promote renal sodium reabsorption.
Vasopressin promotes renal water retention and the feeling of thirst.
Okay.
During dehydration,
adaptive changes in vascular tone,
heart rate and renal reabsorption protect from bro protect us from blood volume
was and a drop in blood pressure.
Urine and sweat become more concentrated to reduce water loss that can become
extreme.
These adaptive changes are extensions of normal homeostatic controls of
electrolyte balance and blood pressure and the limit of adaptation to
dehydration is set by the urine concentrating ability.
The ratio of osmotic pressure in urine to it is about four in humans,
but in Australia and hopping mice,
it's 26 they can produce a urine which is approximately six times more
concentrated than are most concentrated urine.
What about cold and heat?
Our core body temperature is nearly constant as it is in other mammals and in
Burt.
Changes in ambient temperature,
stimulate thermogenesis or heat dissipation.
These normal mechanisms go into overdrive when environmental temperature changes
are extreme.
Cold stimulates the hypothalamus to activate antagonistic skeletal muscles
causing heat to be produced by shivering.
Brown fat produces heat without shivering by uncoupled oxidative
phosphorylation.
So newborn infants and young children have brown fat near vital organs in the
artery supplying them.
So for example,
the arteries to the brain have brown fat deposits around them to keep Brene
temperature constant.
Prolonged cold exposure causes beige a dipocytes to differentiate and they
generate heat by uncoupled oxidative phosphorylation.
Yeah,
so cold adaptation reduces heat dissipation by decreasing blood flow to the skin
and the extremities.
Adaptation to heat increases heat dissipation through increased blood flow to
the skin and activation of sweat glands.
What about hypoxia?
This is an image a 19th century image of Tibetans.
Oxygen is needed for oxidative phosphorylation in Mitochondria.
Tissue's very in their sensitivity to oxygen deprivation.
Our fast twitch muscles generate ATP with quite collossus and they tolerate
short term oxygen shortage,
which is why in the hundred meter dash the sprinters actually don't need to
breathe.
They have enough stored up in their muscles so that they can make it through 10
seconds without needing oxygen.
Neurons and cardiomyocytes rely only on oxidative phosphorylation.
They are exquisitely sensitive to oxygen deprivation.
That's why local ischemia causes myocardial infarction and stroke
oxygen tension declines with exercise and altitude.
The short term responses,
hyperventilation and allocation of oxygen to brain and heart longterm
acclimation to high altitude is mediated by production of era throw potent in
the kidney and that increases red blood cells.
However,
responses to high altitude,
very Indians and Tibetans have higher hemoglobin concentration and percent
oxygen saturation than people at sea level,
but interestingly Ethiopians do not.
There is then our fight or flight response
is activated when a quick response is needed.
For example,
during Predator attack,
it's controlled by the sympathetic nervous system and the hypothalamic pituitary
adrenal axis.
It increases heart rate and respiration and it shifts blood from skeletal muscle
to skeletal muscle and brain.
Okay.
Resources are mobilized.
Glucose,
fatty acids in oxygen and nonessential functions are suppressed,
digestion,
anabolism,
growth and reproduction or all suppressed.
This is an exaggerated version of normal sympathetic control of homeostasis.
Pain is extremely useful.
It's a vital defensive reaction to any mechanical,
chemical or thermal insult and it helps to avoid tissue damage.
The lack of pain perception that is congenital analgesia is a life threatening
condition that is lethal without special measures.
Okay,
so pain receptors,
nociceptors can be activated by both exogenous and endogenous stimuli and
although acute pain normally occurs only with tissue damage,
secondary pain,
which is mediated by c fiber nociceptors plays an important homeostatic roles,
a reminder to the body that something needs fixing.
C fiber nociceptors,
monitor tissue homeostasis by sensing local Ph temperature and metabolites and
the pain reaction is an exaggerated version of these homeostatic responses.
Okay.
Tissue repair
is there to replace cells that are lost during injury that does it with
increased flavor proliferation of tissue stem cells or parenchymal cells.
This is an enhanced version of normal tissue renewal in which tissue stem cells
or continuously producing newly differentiated cells at a rate that's
characteristic.
And varies greatly among tissues.
Tissue regeneration also involves remodeling the extracellular matrix and
angiogenesis,
and it is accompanied by inflammation,
so this is not inflammation as a reaction to disease.
This is inflammation as part of the mechanism of tissue repair,
tissue regeneration and repair correspond to constitutive and inducible
maintenance programs.
They decline with age and they create vulnerability for cancer.
Yeah,
blood clotting is an extremely useful reaction.
It the blood clotting cascade is activated by vascular damage to prevent blood
loss and it promotes repair of damaged blood vessels.
The clotting cascade can be induced by inflammatory signals to prevent
dissemination of pathogens as well.
Although blood clotting per se normally occurs only after vascular damage,
it can be seen as an extension of hemostasis that operates normally to promote
vascular integrity.
Blood vessels cannot operate normally in the absence of platelets and other
components of the clotting machinery,
so in fact like these other functions,
blood clotting is built upon a homeostatic mechanism
to summarize defenses or physiological adaptations that extend normal
homeostatic processes.
They are evolutionary modifications of processes that operate normally in the
absence of a stressor.
The exaggeration of every type of defense produces a characteristic associated
disease.